Donald Trump Jr has now attacked me and
Unleashed a hate mob against me Candace
Owens is in on it the blaze Infowars how
far is this going to go all because of a
tweet that I since deleted which all of
you understood perfectly
I had tweeted about the shooting in
Nashville tongue-in-cheek of course not
literally blaming the victims of the
shooting something I would never do that
it's surprising that there would be a
shooting at a Christian School given
that it's a Christian school and they
pray every single one of you in my
audience understood the point of the
Tweet thoughts and prayers don't prevent
mass shootings but right Wingers people
who don't know me all sorts of different
folks looking to contrive controversy
and send hate my way are saying but
David you're blaming the victims you're
blaming children of course I'm not and
in fact after deleting the Tweet because
of the number of threats that rain down
upon me I put out a video a video where
I said my tweet angered about a million
people and I explained the entire thing
and of course that video has almost 100
percent likes and it has you my viewers
who say David there's not even a
controversy here it's insane that they
even turned this into something but they
did
and now this represents the greatest
existential threat to the David packman
show that we have ever faced that is not
an exaggeration they are going after our
advertisers even though they claim to be
against that tactic they're making
threats not only to me but to others in
my circles I won't even do details
because I might just encourage them more
the situation has reached a fever pitch
Don Jr tweeting yesterday imagine being
this big of a POS to his nearly 10
million followers unfortunately this is
what many on the left think of you if
you have traditional American views and
don't follow blindly and capitulate to
their every lunatic whim truly evil at
this point of course if by traditional
American views Don Jr means doing
nothing
about mass shootings which is exactly
what he and his father's Administration
did and want to do
then yeah that's not for me and of
course then the hate mob descended and
it wasn't just Don Jr Candice Owens
devoted a segment on her show to this
where she was almost in tears over my
tweet posting to Twitter quote more
left-wing filth David packman is
laughing at the fact that the dead
children are Christians who believe in
prayer these are real tweets these
people think it's funny when Christian
children die no I think it's tragic when
thoughts and prayers are the only thing
offered by Republican officials and she
is even going after our advertisers and
this is where this is getting genuinely
bad I wish it wasn't but it is Candace
Owens adding to any of your advertisers
who may be following this this is not a
contrived mob or anti-Semitism this is
you dealing with the consequences of
sending the most horrifically bigoted
tweet directed at dead Christian
children who according to you should
have prayed harder of course that's not
the point the point is thoughts and
prayers don't work who wants to actually
do something about the scourge of gun
violence and yes it's a Scourge that's
how Trump says it and now I say it the
same way a Donald Trump's former lawyer
Jenna Ellis
getting in on it this is a horrific take
that the author didn't walk back just
said he's now getting harassed so
deleted it David Pacman you harassed
Christians and should apologize for this
offensive tweet targeting our sincere
Faith No I'm targeting anyone who says
thoughts and prayers and nothing else
Jenna Ellis says evil persists and we
don't represent prayer as a complete
Shield to The Perils of the Fallen World
but rather than through faith in Christ
we can accept salvation and live it I
mean it just you know religious Babel
now
Thessalonians tells us give me a break
the right wing blaze writing an article
about this they weren't praying enough
progressive radio host goes viral over
vile reaction to Christian school
massacre
thoughts and prayers don't stop mass
shootings that's the point
Infowars is it possible they weren't
praying enough David pakman mocks
Christians murdered by trans shooter in
Nashville
and the wrongest man in the world on the
pandemic Alex Berenson also tweeting
just apologize David packman you were
shameful not just for what you said did
you think it was funny blaming kids for
their own deaths is beyond awful because
in your non-apology you then blamed
anti-Semitism for the response blame
yourself not your religion not blaming
My Religion but you should see
thousands
thousands of anti-Semitic messages
Jew the k word ovens uh uh people
suggesting they're going to come and do
this that the other thing to this and
that the other person I'm not even gonna
I don't I don't even want to put it out
there because it's a deluge where a
security has been contracted and so on
and so forth it you have no idea what's
going on it's wild it is wild so they
are sending the hate mob against us and
we now have to see whether we can
weather this storm most of you reached
out with uh support it's been great
hearing from you know the one upside
when these things happen
is the messages from people who have
been in the audience for a long time and
I got so many messages from people
saying David none of these people are in
your audience we all know what you meant
thoughts and prayers do nothing we've
got to do something about gun violence
you're a father you're frustrated it's
disgusting what's going on don't even
worry about it it'll pass it'll pass uh
I heard from I guess I shouldn't even
say but many of the people you know in
our Circle who do shows like mine they
reached out to me privately and said
this is really bad these are people who
don't know anything about you they don't
follow the show they have seized on to
something to take attention away from
the fact that they have nothing to offer
to actually stop the shootings so we are
getting crushed right now and the best
thing you can do is leave a comment
leave a like try to push back against
this mob which remember isn't even in
our audience and of course if you can
get a membership at joinpakman.com
please do we have the coupon code cancel
cancel
cancel the cancellation that they are
trying to do let me now talk more about
what it is they are trying to do